[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' envies de lecture autour de
moi trois invités aujourd'hui jacques
présentez vous bonjour je suis directeur
d itinéraire poétique un des services de
la direction du rayonnement culturel de
saint quentin en yvelines et je vais
vous présenter en cette actualité de la
commémoration de l'armistice de 18 ce
texte magnifique de blaise cendrars j'ai
tué publié en 1918 parfait
gabriel de prochaine bonjour cet auteur
oui d'un
d'un roman d'un thriller que vous venez
de sortir et vous allez aussi vous
parler aujourd'hui d'un coup de coeur
oui tout à fait je suis auteur donc du
livre je voudrais existe est un roman et
qui est sorti en début d'année mais ce
n'est pas de cela dont je vais vous
parler c'est d'un coup de coeur que j'ai
eue pour ce livre de philippe claudel
qui s'appelle le rapport de brodeck
sorti en 2007 et dont je vois la joie de
vous parler un shooter parfait ophélie
félix bonjour présentez-vous vache est
chargé des arts visuels pour la
direction du rayonnement culturel
services de l'agglomération comme
jacques et aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler d'une histoire de seins donc
c'est un petit livre pour les enfants et
donc c'est le mot qui commence donc je
vais le présenter toute la vie donc
c'est un livre que j'ai retrouvé en fait
si je voulais apporter aujourd'hui c'est
parce que je les retrouvais dans ma
bibliothèque ce week end
c'est un livre qui m'a beaucoup est élu
et que j'ai aussi beaucoup lui à mes
propres enfants et que j'ai beaucoup
aimé donc la première édition c'est 1968
donc c'est vrai que voilà c'est un
classique de gilbert gatore et il a
toujours autant de succès puisque les
enfants sont pas si vieux peintre qui
sont ados maintenant et je l'avais
beaucoup donc ce petit livre là il est
superbement illustré par quercy chapelet
c'est aussi ça qui me plaît comme chez
chargé des arts visuels je vous apporte
un livre dont j'aime le destin donc
c'est l'histoire d'un petit singe qui il
dès tout petit tout petit dans sa
famille personne ne le voit et du coup
il part à l'aventuré et paris va lui
arriver tout un tas de bricoles et
notamment il va tomber dans l'eau et il
va
je suis comme ça et il va rencontrer un
énorme crocodile qui s'appelle rokocoko
toc min et des tout-petits donc
normalement ben ils devraient pas s'en
sortir mais finalement comme il est très
rusé il va réussir à attraper un
crocodile grâce à l'éléphant qui est la
voie la plus sûre les loges $ us et un
livre sur voilà on est on est on a beau
être tout petit on arrive quand même à
partir à l'aventuré à se débrouiller
avec dollar us parce que finalement
quand même 5 pour les enfants donc tout
se passe bien il arrive à attraper le
crocodile grâce à l'éléphant
voilà
et puis à la fin évidemment donc le
crocodile il s'en va l'éléphant leur
amène chez sa maman et il a il raconte
qu'il a attrapé un crocodile donc comme
il est tout petit tout le monde tout le
monde rigole l éléphant dit mais non
bien sûr il a attrapé un crocodile
voilà donc et ça se finit évidemment par
une fête et ensuite dans les bras de sa
maman
comme vous voyez mon exemplaire il est
très vieux oui réutilisés mais il a été
réédité jeu preuve la dernière réédition
je sais plus 2005 ou à l'inversé rld et
de thagaste auriez une réédition des
grands classiques dont il souffre
à chaque fois il est réédité et je crois
qu'il existe aussi en audio donc ce qui
est très chouette avec ce livre c'est
que quand vous le raconter à vos enfants
avant moi je les fais en tout cas on
peut prendre plusieurs voix la voix des
petits sans j'avais des crocodiles et la
vallée des forts disait on peu
théâtralisé et ensuite
ouais c'est pas mal et ensuite en fait
comme il est il est très court les
enfants m'aiment beaucoup ont le rallye
plusieurs fois et nous parents on le
connaît par coeur et donc du coup on
regarde juste les attentes et à autant
de plusieurs fois et allez vous vivre
il avait tellement que c'est tous les
soirs pendant longtemps
donc j'espère que vous l'aimerez parce
que vous allez lui raconter souvent
parfait jacques hesse pouvez nous parler
de cet ouvrage j'ai tué alors c'est une
des éditions de j'ai tué de blaise
cendrars parce qu' on a eu plein et la
première étape du exactement du 8
novembre 1918 de blaise cendrars et est
parti à la guerre en septembre 14 après
avoir lancé un appel aux artistes
étrangers à défendre la france et en
septembre 15 il y les blessés sont
une paire son bras droit son bras
d'écriture qui est coupé au dessus du
coude et il apprend à écrire de la main
gauche et en février 18
il écrit un texte qui s'appelle j'ai tué
qui est un texte très court qui dans ce
livre fait onze pages qui est une qui
raconte un des moments qu'il a vécu en
étant aux tranchées puisqu'il était dans
son escouade il était chargé de nettoyer
les tranchées dans la somme et il
raconte un de ces moments mais il ne
fait pas que raconter ce moment-là il
explique aussi pourquoi cette guerre est
une véritable aberration même s'il y a
participé parce qu'il voulait y
participer il ne fait pas partie des des
réfractaires ou des pacifistes c'est pas
du tout sa position je sais une position
qui se défend aussi complètement et ce
texte est tout simplement un appel à la
la comment dire à la à l'humanité est
surtout le fait de
dans ce texte il dit tout simplement une
chose très simple il dit l'humanité
entière a fait en sorte que cette guerre
puisse exister grâce à moi j'ai tué
grâce à toute l'humanité
mais l'humanité mais vraiment toute
l'humanité c'était une première guerre
mondiale certes mais avant de la définir
comme tels lui dit c'est une véritable
guerre parce que tout le monde ya
participé
les uns ont parfois pratiqué fabriquer
des armes les autres ont apporté des
chevaux les autres ont fabriqué les
vêtements c'est un texte d'une puissance
incroyable quand il a été édité
c'est donc le 8 novembre 1918 la veille
de la mort d'apollinaire trois jours
avant l'armistice il a eu de la censure
l'a autorisé la publication ce texte là
il a été édité dans une édition ché ché
ché ché baignoire d'une façon très
particulière c'était un livre car et un
petit livre car est imprimé en typo
rouge avec des dessins de braque c'était
la première fois que bright c'était
fernand léger ferme de fernand léger
pardon c'était la première fois que
fernand léger collaboré un livre
d'artiste qui n'en fera d'autres sucre
est venu lui-même avait été blessé au
front voilà c'est une c'est surtout une
cette idée c'est cette dent ce texte là
ils ennuient en aura d'autres après
puisque en 46 et 47 blessés cendrars
publiera d'autres récits dans la main
coupée et jean l'homme foudroyé des
récits bas seulement des récits de
guerre mais d'autres encore
et les publiera après la de la seconde
guerre mondiale mais ce texte n'a été
dit et dans cette édition la cds
éditions zoé
c'est une maison d'édition suisse et ce
texte j'ai tué complété d'un autre texte
plus long publié en 1938 lui qui
s'appelle j'ai saigné
qui est ce qui s'est passé pour blaise
cendrars à l'hôpital de chalon après sa
blessure jamais blaise cendrars ne
racontait sa blessure jamais il écrit un
seul texte disant voilà comment ça s'est
passé dans la main coupée il vit un
moment je vais vous le raconter il n'a
jamais fait et donc ce texte j'ai saigné
est un texte
initiateur de ce qu'il va vivre de ce
qu'il va de ce qu'il a vécu ce qu'il a
vécu rien
à sa manière c'est à dire que chez
blaise cendrars on ne sait jamais faire
la part des choses entre la réalité et
la fiction
c'est un romancier faut pas oublier ça
c'est un certes certains très grand
poète mais c'est aussi un très grand
romancier c'est à sac abouti d'une cette
immense machine de guerre des femmes se
crèvent dans les usines un peuple
d'ouvriers trima outrance au fond des
mines des savants des savates des
inventeurs s'ingénie la merveilleuse
activités humaines est prise attribue la
richesse d'un siècle de travail intensif
l'expérience de plusieurs civilisations
sur toute la surface de la terre
on ne travaille que pour moi voilà il en
arrive donc à tuer un homme dans les
tranchées et il faut lire aussi dans la
main coupée qu'en réalité cet homme qui
l'a tué d'une certaine manière ce soldat
allemand qui l'a tuée était déjà mort et
c'est ce geste qu'il a eue de le tuer au
couteau dans la tranchée c'était un
geste de peur et sept hommes étaient
déjà morts parce qu'ils avaient était
touché par un obus et lorsqu'il l'a
découvert dans les tranchées face à lui
il lavait les mains sur son ventre il
tenait ces boyaux
donc c'est un texte d'une force
incroyable et pour information ce texte
là
moi j'ai le plaisir de le mettre en
scène exactement cent ans jour pour jour
après sa publication le 8 novembre 2018
dans la salle de la volière au tremblay
sur mauldre dans le village où a vécu
blaise cendrars pendant vingt ans où il
avait une maison pendant 20 ans et ce
sera un texte qui sera joué 10 par la
comédienne véronique ellena malvoisin où
ce sera le 8 novembre à 20h30 au
tremblay sur mauldre chez blaise
cendrars très bien merci
le rendez vous est pris c'est un des
textes les plus les plus forts les plus
dérangeants sur la première guerre
mondiale
alors vous gabriel beauchesne la guerre
ça vous oui parce que donc ce livre que
je vais présenter
on parle aussi des périphéries de la
guerre mais c'est la deuxième guerre
mondiale puisque ça se passe dans un
petit village pas loin de la frontière
allemande
et ça raconte l'histoire d'un homme
brodeck qui est un homme un petit peu
comme tout le monde et qui était dans
son village au moment de cette guerre
est dénoncée par les autres personnes du
village par un camp de concentration
donc il passe une ou deux années en camp
de concentration puis revient au village
et lorsqu'il revient y son regard a
changé sur le village il a l'impression
que son village a changé les gens du
village ont changé en tout cas qui s'est
passé des choses quand il n'était pas là
et il ya également un fait étonnant
c'est que un étranger est venu
s'installer dans le village donc c'est
comme ça qu'on le désigne l'étranger
dans ce dans ce livre s'était tranché
c'est un peintre et il regarde les
habitants du village
il dessine les habitants du village il
prend des notes sur eux et ça dérange
tout le monde alors ça dérange tout le
monde pour diverses raisons qu'on va
comprendre au fil au fil du texte est
cet étrange et finit par agacer
tellement qui au cours d'une après un
vernissage fin au cours de deux d'un
rassemblement du village il est tué par
tous les gens du village sauf brodeck
qui n'était pas présent et le conseil
municipal décide de demander à brodeck
d'écrire un rapport pour justifier la
mort de cet homme parce que c'était
peut-être la personnalité de brodeck
c'était aussi parce que c'était la seule
personne du village qui savaient écrire
et qui avait une machine à écrire et
donc on lui demande de faire ce rapport
on se dit aussi que c'est une personne
un peu simple et qu' il va écrire ce
qu'on a prévu qu'il écrive un don qui
commença à écrire ce rapport est fait
finalement une enquête sur le village et
il se rend compte qu'il s'est passé des
choses et ils découvrent un certain
nombre de choses notamment ce qui s'est
passé dans sa propre famille puisque
quand il est revenu sa femme ne parlait
plus et il savait pas pourquoi
et donc voilà donc il écrit ce rapport
est alors moi ça m'a touché ce livre
parce que ce brodeck on s'aperçoit
pendant le livre qu'il a tenus en camp
de concentration parce qu'il sait
laisser humilier
c'est ça qui l'a sauvée il le dit et il
revient et donc il s'est passé aussi des
choses allant donner il était dans le
train avec une femme et son enfant et il
mourrait tous deux soient faits il a
pris de l'eau est ensuite la femme est
morte et donc ils se sont aussi
coupables un certain nombre de choses
mais ce que veut m à mon avis un
philippe claudel c'est en lumière ces de
ces deux positions qu'on peut avoir par
rapport à l'horreur donc soit la
pollution du village qui cherche à nier
soit lui même qui se rend compte de la
réalité de sa pauvreté et c'est ça qui
est très beau parce que donc il va
écrire ce rapport et il va l'écrire en
surprenant tout le monde puisqu'il va
écrire la vérité
donc c'est aussi la vérité faso face aux
mensonges et face à la manière dont les
gens se mentent à eux-mêmes pour pouvoir
oublier les horreurs qu'ils ont fait et
donc il va faire ce rapport est bon là
je raconte pas la fin mais il ya
vraiment il ya vraiment cette cette
notion cette ambivalence de l'homme face
à l'horreur voilà donc notre chaîne pour
cette découverte voilà au pdi félix et
chaque fois n'ai je vous avez tous les
poulets de 20 secondes
voilà pour nous donner l'actualité la
gêne dans votre agenda
alors l'agenda moi je vous invite à
venir les 6 octobre à la commanderie où
qu'ils se trouvent sur la ville
d'elancourt où on va fêter on va faire
une nuit blanche à la commanderie donc
vous aurez de la danse une pièce
chorégraphique dif radia dans la
chapelle vous aurez une exposition qui
s'appelle corps mouvement et innovation
dans le bâtiment des garde assez une
expo sciences et vous aurez évidemment
des arts visuels donc une installation
immersive où son corps se transforme en
constellation et de la vidéo projection
sur les façades lot 6 octobre à la
commanderie 19 heures mini et jacques
qu'il était très rapide mais à la
qualité c'est déjà été celui novembre
avec la présentation du lieu la lecture
de j'ai tué d'autres
d'autres récits de guerre de blaise
cendrars ce sera surtout en novembre
pour nous la semaine des écrivains
persécutés emprisonnés empêcher avec un
concert en l'église
saint georges à trappes et une grande
soirée le 15 novembre à la batterie à
guyancourt avec nos invités et le
collectif en performance le tympan
marteau parfait merci à vous il avoir
suivi dans c'était dans cette nouvelle
émission envies de lecture et je vous
donne rendez-vous à très bientôt pour de
prochains coups de coeur et de
prochaines lectures
merci à vous
[Musique]